نحن نتابع عن كثب هذا
الوضع المقلق للغاية الذي
نراه حاليًا في إيران ، حيث أن
التسمم المستمر لفتيات المدارس في جميع أنحاء
إيران أمر غير معقول ، يجب أن يكون هناك
تحقيق مستقل موثوق به
ومحاسبة المسؤولين إذا كانت
حالات التسمم هذه مرتبطة
بالمشاركة في الاحتجاج.  من الجيد
ضمن تفويض
بعثة تقصي الحقائق الدولية المستقلة التابعة للأمم المتحدة بشأن
إيران التحقيق في أن النساء والفتيات في
كل مكان لهن حق أساسي في
التعليم مرارًا وتكرارًا ، فقد
ثبت أنه عندما تتلقى النساء والفتيات
التعليم ويستطعن
المساهمة في  إن اقتصاداتهم
تفيد المجتمع ككل ، لذا فإن
احتمال تعرض الفتيات في إيران للتسمم
لمجرد محاولة
الحصول على التعليم أمر مخز
وغير مقبول